[Music]
it is good to be back in the studio
what is up homies it is the lef koe man
and I am joined by a very special guest
today his name is Warren sharp you've
heard me mention it many times I read
his book we've shared some DMS and now
you're here live in the studio it's good
to have you man I'm happy to be here I
want to get into who you are what you're
doing how I feel like it's been 20 18 19
the year of you and everyone looking at
analytics and not being afraid in the
NFL anymore I think it went from well
this is a sport where we don't do
analytics - holy [ __ ] maybe we should
throw the ball on first down so I want
to get to all that but let me just talk
to the homies really quick if that's
cool all right so guys I've been on the
road and this has been insane and I'm
just gonna open it up to you and be
honest I was in Atlanta I did the whole
fast-break thing and I was live for four
days I think I did like 32 hours of live
TV which I'm gonna be honest it'll knock
your ass out Warren it's a little crazy
from that I went to Lexington did a
shoot with Josh Allen could be a top
five pick out of Kentucky that podcast
will be coming I think in two weeks
we're gonna do a bunch of draft
prospects I recently interviewed John
Abram the safety out of Mississippi
State and I'm telling you right now it
is the most honest interview I've ever
had he came after Nick Bosa he called
himself the best safety in the draft all
he wants to do was pop people and I may
or may not have freestyle in the
beginning of the interview it may have
come out so that's coming up in the next
few weeks as well just to kind of break
it down this is I'm happy to be back
we're gonna do a little bit of news and
notes with Warren and then we're gonna
kind of get into his story and then yeah
next week I'm gonna be in Minneapolis
for the final four doing some Twitter
live shows at the Final Four if you live
in Minneapolis I know we had a good time
at Super Bowl last year hit me up on
social and we can make this work all
right
so Warren
NFL League meetings are going on and
every year there's a new rule on the
table and every year nothing happens so
I didn't read into it for real this year
but now all pass interference calls can
be challenged calls non calls and I'm
I'm shocked I'm surprised I thought that
what we saw with the Nickell Roby
Coleman hit was a once-in-a-lifetime non
call I thought it was a freak occurrence
in your world it's a supreme outlier and
yet we're changing this now and I saw
you tweet out what happens in Hail Marys
because if you've ever seen a highlight
of a Hail Mary there's like 17 stiff
arms it is this good for right now and
maybe bad long-term like what's your
read on this whole thing I think it's
good because the league is being
progressive and technology is improving
we have more camera angles better camera
speed better camera operators so it
makes perfect sense to be able to
incorporate that technology to better
sure get the games right and I think one
of the big things that the league has
like Goodell the Commissioner is always
about the integrity of the league the
integrity of leaked well it doesn't look
very good on the league when they have
the ability to use replay but yet
they're having these egregious calls and
that's all anybody's talking about for
the very next week after a game and so
Tim you tweeted out the video of it and
you were like can you imagine and got
like 67,000 likes
yeah because it was a seminal moment of
a video that was so blatant but slow
motion of pass interference call
sometimes are wildly subjective oh yes
and and this one that's what I mean this
one was so blatant but I don't think
they're gonna be this blatant in the
future I could see us sitting there and
watching a high light replays for five
minutes at the end of a game and I don't
know like it kind of scares me to be on
it should I think it should scare all
the fans because we don't really know I
think the good one good thing about it
is that we probably aren't going to have
as many coaches challenge spot fouls
like spot spot because they're going to
want to save those penalties
you know challenges for when there's
something like a pass interference call
the team that's down in a game
always will have now the option to throw
the ball deep inside that 2 minutes and
the coach doesn't even have to use the
challenge of course the penalty could
come on that team it could be OPI
offensive but yeah you know I think
that's the part I'm most concerned about
I'm ok with a coach being able to once a
game challenge something that the refs
just missed I mean they're going to make
mistakes and miss what's going to happen
though you're right we're gonna have
situations where all the announcers are
going to talk about well the coaches are
out of their challenges and that was one
that should be challenged and now on
every single time that there is a
question we'll replay yeah you know that
the coaches don't have challenges
anymore the the commentators are just
gonna keep talking about it obsessively
during the game OMG they're a tour of
the booth right so they're going to be
very annoying situations where it's
going to kind of invade the rest of our
viewing pleasure of watching the game
because we're always going to be
thinking on every pass could this be
challenged and if the guy actually had
challenges would this have been
overturned is there a way to use this
strategically for coaches like you were
saying like last two minutes of the game
does it just become lob City and you're
kind of looking for contact and try to
initiate contact because now we're gonna
we're gonna go to the booth we're gonna
go to New York right well there's
certain types of routes are more likely
to draw p.i calls on the defense you're
gonna talk dirty to me so so what are
the routes well so it's the go routes
get some of the most yeah also some of
like your deep post routes your fly
routes like those are the types of
routes that get the most calls the the
balls were like the air yards on the
past are like 20-plus yards down the
field the short routes you can jam
inside the first five yards you can hold
a little bit anyways so those calls
aren't you know the short passes aren't
going to be as plus evie but the deeper
passes where this could be utilized so I
think there will be coaches that are
going to strategically and not all of
them get on this as quickly you know
you're gonna have like the Baltimore
Ravens who still wants to run the
football town and the Dallas Cowboys who
still wants to run the football at time
yeah but some of the more progressive
coaches are going to realize that some
of the deeper passes look at the
Philadelphia Eagles they just got the
Sean Jackson Carson Wentz has a ton of
accuracy down the field but he doesn't
he wasn't able to keep healthy players
on those deep passes down the field Matt
Collins got hurt all those guys got last
year even
year before during when they want
suitable tours yes not her it wasn't
there at the end so now you got the Sean
Jackson he can run those deep routes
that are called often on P eyes so those
types of teams where they throw the ball
down the field oh but more often are
gonna be able to stand to gain more I
just can already feel it happening in
like a week 1 week 2 game where we're
sitting there and it's Al Michaels and
Collinsworth and we're going is this
gonna be a whole season of this it
should be interesting I thought the news
that I heard Rappaport saying was
Belichick is a reason this got passed
and the story that he said on NFL
Network was they're getting ready to go
to lunch and take that famous coach's
picture which they take every year and
Belichick said let's eat lunch in here
and let's get this done because it's
very rare that the owners ratify
something that the coaches are trying to
pass usually we've seen this in years
past where the coaches leave and the
owners pass something and the coaches
are like what the hell just happened
so it's weird the coach has got this
done but I it feels good it feels like
we get the Sean Payton memes of him
smiling and it feels good but like if
I'm a Saints fan I mean this doesn't
make me feel any better about last year
it doesn't know but it feels right but I
could also see it getting really
annoying very quickly it could the one
weird weird thing that could happen is
it could be something like the helmet to
helmet rule which was such a massive
story overhauled and preseason right and
then and then they just went back in the
season and completely dialed it back all
of our fears came to nothing because it
was rarely called
only in the most egregious situations
but I think it's like it's now floating
out that they might sign Colin
Kaepernick then seeing the reaction and
they're like oh no we're the Baltimore
Ravens we shouldn't do that you know you
let the air balloon go up see what house
responses but I do think because the
coaches can challenge this it'll be
interesting to see how those rulings go
if the ruling is like in the first few
rulings in the season in the regular
season if the ruling is like well it
wasn't egregious enough then maybe we
won't see it quite as often if the
coaches lose their challenges because
it's not clear and obvious but as you
mentioned earlier most passes tend to
have P I there's gravity there's tugging
I show in their little something if you
can get like on a 30-yard pass down the
field or
pass into the end zone where a guy just
grabbed the guy's arm for a second and
then they're gonna give you first and
goal on the one then coaches are gonna
exploit that
how much do awesome all right so the
voice you're hearing again is Warren
Sharpe you can follow on social media at
sharp football I'm just reading your
Twitter bio predictive NFL Analects and
visualized data at sharp football
analysis calm you do work for almost
everybody at this point and I realized
we need to introduce you before we get
to some of the news and notes we're
gonna get to Cam Newton we're gonna get
to Jean wins Winston getting fat and
we're gonna get to Colt McCoy drinking
milk trust me
but where did you come from and because
I feel like you've been this rocket ship
that's come out of nowhere what's the
story how do you explain this to people
in your in your elevator pitch so I have
a light professional engineering license
I study school civil engineering got my
degree worked in that field but while I
was in college I was developing computer
algorithms for sports betting and I is
this for your own betting or for friends
or for for a little bit of everything so
I developed it for myself first and
foremost started posting back that was
this is back before Twitter so I was
posting on message boards I was posting
here's what I think is gonna happen in
these games you know these are the bets
that I would take you know this is what
I'm doing this is what you guys should
like just track and they started doing
really well and so after a couple years
of that like some guys who actually bet
big-time out in Las Vegas work with some
of the biggest names that you know of in
the sports betting world reached out to
me like hey come out to Las Vegas we
want to talk to you they're looking for
the they're looking for the edge so they
wanted to get my information you know on
the side so I started doing that then I
started posting a blog and putting stuff
out there and developed a little website
where as putting stuff out there and
then I got more and more into the
analytics side of things because that
was giving me a bigger edge with what I
was betting on I was basically
discovering that the more that I study
the intricate matchups and the edges the
more that I could I know the Vegas
sports books they're not looking at that
information you'll look at things like
how does a team defend interior runs
versus the success of an offenses
ability to run in the interior and and
see oh there's a huge gap here what one
team is far superior to the other and it
doesn't mean that's how the game is
gonna go but it could be an edge that
teaches you about over-unders or totals
or something like that exactly so I try
to use everything that I glean from you
know to help me in my sports betting but
sharing so much on social media and new
information and I've caught up with him
research and the book that I wrote
attracts the attention of teams there
are so many teams that are out there
that are kind of like surfing Twitter
and looking for information and nuggets
that can help them what year was the
first year of team contact actually it
was a few years ago that a team
contacted me a couple various teams did
and I talked with people there but it
never developed into anything last year
was the first year that a team actually
there were four teams that were very
serious and reached out I ended up
signing on board with one team to be
consulting with them and help them come
up with their game plans for their
opponents each week holy [ __ ] that's
amazing it was a lot of fun - you'll
have to say the team or no I can't I
sign NDA so I'm not allowed to share
that but this size an NDA - I'm working
with a team - I just can't tell you then
this season we've got like nine to ten
teams that are interested and
negotiating which ones that I'm gonna
end up working with I can't work with
all of them because there's only one of
me
but we're gonna be working with a small
handful of teams again this year just
helping them on a week-to-week basis and
I love doing that it's a ton of fun
because now you can turn your ideas and
concepts not just to use like armchair
quarterbacking after the fact oh I said
they should have done this you can
actually help the team's preventatively
not make the mistakes and do the right
things look I I was going through and I
thought your section of the beginning
where it's like the big picture stuff
you had so many nuggets in there that I
thought interesting one the one that I
felt was the biggest one was like the
early success downs and throwing on
first downs and focusing on running
backs and tight ends but even I remember
looking at the Kansas City Chiefs
chapter and going this defense is
decimated he mahomes is gonna be a lot
more aggressive than than Alan Smith I
could invest fantasy on the Kansas City
Chiefs offense and I look back at that
now and I go man all over it
the thing about football is and I'm
curious football sometimes you could
have all the data it could all make
sense and then a game just goes the
other [ __ ] way and how do you because
I've seen a lot of analysts they get
shredded online because oh you said this
would happen then the score indicated
otherwise how do you process that and
again that there's not a ton of
statistics there's only 16 games how do
you balance that yeah it's it's tough I
mean there's it's a small sample size as
you mentioned and there's a lot of
variance the football balance is
different ways and we know that the team
that wins the turnover battle wins 80%
of these games so you could be right on
a lot of what you're saying and the
result isn't what you thought it was
going to be because of a pick six or
because of a turnover on the 20 and then
you didn't even get any points let alone
a field goal so you just have to be
diligent and thorough about what you are
forecasting and you're gonna be right I
mean if you do it the right way you're
gonna be right more often than you're
wrong and at the end of the day it's
about the process as opposed to the
actual results because there's so much
variance and then eventually that
consistency will lead you to that
vaunted 60% number right what's the best
you've ever done one NFL season on my
totals I hit 71% fell amazing oh yeah
well how do you say how does Warren
Sharpe celebrate a season after that but
I either I take I take I take a nap a
siesta man cuz I work so much I work so
much I'm working like til 3:00 a.m. each
night during the season really
yeah what's what's uh what's a Sunday
for you during the season oh it's like a
charting while watching the games or you
just watch the games and processing I'm
taking notes I'm taking notes during the
game so I've got in my office I've got a
bank of six computer monitors sure and
then I've got my was it like a 10-foot
projection screen surrounded by monitors
on either side that so I can watch yeah
I put the DirecTV all eight games in the
box on the main TV watch reso no you
don't know I do I do all eight games and
then I do the two side TVs so I can fit
maximum of ten games on at once and
there's never more than ten no that way
and but it does frustrate me when they
put nine
at the 1 p.m. slavery or to it they fall
exactly what is going on right it's
right so I might be one of the only
people in this world that has the
capability to watch as many games as you
like we have that set up where I can do
that how the hell do you watch all the
games because I will put red zone on one
just to listen to the audio I don't
watch red zone but it'll catch me up if
I missed a screen over there but like
what what's your system for watching all
these games at the same time well I said
I said dead center right in the middle
of everything and then I kind of week
one it's hard right it's an adjustment
but after that like your brain picks it
back up because it's like riding a
bicycle you remember and and you kind of
are just aware oh well these two games
are on commercial and this game you know
they just punted and and so you kind of
know so I'm constantly looking around at
the different and I rarely listen to the
audio because most of the commentators I
mean some of them might listen to you I
don't want to hurt their feelings but
most of its kind of worthless so yeah
yeah it doesn't really matter if you're
not hearing what they all said sure as
long as you're catching it with your
eyes and then what I do is after the
games are over I'll go back you know
Sunday night maybe Monday morning and
watch a little bit of luck sometimes
I'll watch the yeah yeah watch the quick
like 30 minutes a game in 30 minutes
type deal I won't go back and watch the
whole game unless there's something that
I need to if there's an injury you got
to see how the guy was carted off the
field or how he got off the field
there's a lot of different things that
you might be wanting to look into that
you know what kind of content are you
putting out after 3:00 a.m. on Sunday
like what what is the material that
you're making is it looking ahead
already to the next week it's a little
bit of both I'm I'm working I'm starting
my work for the team so I'm working on
the reports for the teams so that's what
information do they want well they want
to know for the next week how they're
gonna best prepare for their opponent so
I'm looking out the games that they just
just played I'm looking at I don't
really look at a lot of data that goes
back season-long although I will
incorporate that but I'm looking at like
the last four weeks primarily what their
team did what the opponent did self
scouting what do they need to improve
looking at the defense how our opponents
attacking them what's successful what's
not or but I do I'm doing a lot of that
but then on my website I have a stats
website that's free to use so I'm
updating all that data visualize stat
site so then
everybody who wants to you or anybody
else can go there and research and look
at you know what what personal groupings
was this team using and how successful
were they so you can find all that
information you on Monday for the games
that were just played on Sunday so a lot
of the advanced charting data is
available to the public the homies know
this part of the reason I had the Texans
doing so well this year was I looked at
your strength of schedule and
opposition's and I was like this is this
is wild how easy their schedule is when
I'm looking at it before the season and
the sad part was it was even easier than
what it appeared to be because of all
the backup quarterbacks that they ended
up facing I mean have you put together a
list of a list of the quarterbacks that
they played it was a dream schedule and
that's why you know when they went up
against the Eagles I bet the over and
that game was like 33 to 30 right and
then I knew that they were gonna
probably get bounced early in the
playoffs because they had an easy path
to get there but then they're gonna have
to play the Colts like they're an
awesome opportunity to bet against for
this upcoming season if there's a little
of a kind of momentum for people there
yeah like some time and then you see the
Patriots and you go man existing in the
AFC East really has been a wonder for
this team for quite some time
oh and especially now you got the
Dolphins and in the middle of a deep
rebuild get rid of Tannehill so you know
you don't know exactly what their future
is gonna be well they draft a
quarterback this draft what were they
what will they end up doing at the
quarterback position so the Jets you
know the Jets look like they've got some
hope the Colts it all depends how Josh
Allen performs there because he's got
such a wide range of expectations you
know he's got a great deep arm what you
get you're under at for the bills I got
him at six
and so I [ __ ] push yeah we got we got
it at seven when I first met it lucky it
was but we got down so we know some of
the people out in Las Vegas you run
these books so we were able to get
higher limits than what their normal
ticket that they were gonna sell it
South Point was three dimes right we
were able to get five on it now that's
still in the grand consideration you're
gonna have more than that on a regular
game during the week so to have that all
tied up on just the full season you
explain dimes to everybody else it's a
thousand dollars yeah yeah so it's I
mean and generally you're speaking the
to win amount so you're gonna win five
dimes of your betting six at the juice
that we put down to get to five but
that's what you're going to go and walk
away with yeah because the preseason
bets are my most fun I had a situation
Lauren you'll appreciate this last game
of the year I took over seven and a half
or over seven for the Dolphins preseason
and under six for the bills and because
the bills won that game I pushed both
nice it was a killer yeah that's not
good but you know those those things
happen I mean that's why you got to jump
on them as you know like the earlier the
better but some of the times you're you
are struggling to figure out exactly
what you have to do or is there an
injury you want to wait around for like
a lot of times you will want to wait
until that third preseason game to make
sure your starting quarterback it's
gonna be helped you see that before so
so if you're gonna bet in over you may
want to wait unless you think the line
is completely wrong if you're gonna bet
in under hey any injury helps unless
it's to like some key defensive players
that will happen in the preseason or
something like that all right so I am
someone I'm a gut better so I am someone
that like I'll look at you know what the
Steelers right now take it on the
Raiders this feels like a letdown kind
of game I'm going like that when you see
a lot of me I on the people that on the
public betting I really am I embody them
to a tee but I love listening to you
guys to guide to not be as public or
I'll watch late line changes or I'll see
sharp money come on what are some tips
for people like me the average public to
stop being public what what are a few
key things that we can do to fix our
game without having to have nine
monitors 10 televisions all that stuff
the easiest thing you can do is don't
put what just happened with your
eyeballs at the front of what you decide
to do for next week's games because
everybody bets off of what they just saw
and a lot of time to see Titans rule the
Tennessee Titans are the ultimate team
they're like beat the Patriots and then
[ __ ] the bed exactly exactly so you know
especially because in in Las Vegas they
do look at headlines look at headlines
will tell you like the week before the
game what the line they're projecting
could be and that you can actually bet
on those if you want the limits aren't
high but you can actually bet on those
so for example if you saw that the
Tennessee Titans were catching
six and a half points in two weeks
against the Rams okay and then the week
before that they beat the Patriots at
home 32:13 whatever the score was and
then that six and a half drops down to
four so next week you're only getting
plus four and it was plus six and a half
you don't want to bet the Titans at plus
four because you know that there's a
massive overreaction to what just
happened so look at the look of
headlines and then see the the second
one is check the very late line moves at
a sports book like pinnacle u there's a
lot of free odd services out there I've
got one up at my website but you can
find them anywhere
that basically chart out like what the
line movement is and it's like updated
in real time yeah and so you want to
look for where some of the late money is
going on games if you say late game
kicks off at one o'clock
are we talking noon we're talking like
12:45 twelve fifty that late because at
oftentimes I get a book like pinnacle
they will be begging for money on the
team that you should be betting against
so they'll be giving if they've got the
best number on it best line on the game
let's let's pretend that the line is the
Giants are playing the the Redskins sure
the Giants are at home and the Giants
are leading three points but the juice
if people know about that is minus 125
you have to bet a hundred twenty-five
dollars to win a hundred but at Pinnacle
it's minus three plus 100 meaning 100
gets you a hundred and most of the other
books are - 120 - 125 - 130 they are
begging you to take the Giants at that
cheap number Wow so it's so hard to
resist it
it would be but you don't want it you
they are very sharp a book so you want
to see what they're begging for because
that means the sharp guys are betting
the other way so what you're saying
right now is if if you look at the books
and you're saying pinnacle right now and
its pinnacle I guess one of these being
the time offshore take time offshore
splits book you you look at them and if
you see a Vig that's like really off and
they're trying to invite betting and
even at your own sports book kind of
flip it a little bit yeah at your own
book yeah look look at what pinnacle is
begging for and bet the opposite way at
your own book wow that's a wild yeah
I mean that's just one tip and you want
to do that like very close to the time
that we can hear people say Vegas just
always knows why does it seem like
they're able to have such an advantage
why is it that the public is at such a
disadvantage compared to these casinos
well the public bets on emotion so often
the public chases their losses so often
so Vegas constantly has the ability to
like take in more money mean that's why
they're building those casinos out there
so nice so they're taking a lot of
square money into the marketplace and
they're charging you for it too making
you pay the Vig 110 to win 100s cetera
and so you really have to be I mean
you're not going to strike it rich most
people are not gonna strike it rich
betting on sports so you just got to be
careful especially the NFL understand
that you're doing it as a hobby it's fun
it's something to talk about it's
something to analyze and now it's
legalized so making it even more fun you
talked about NFL teams contacting you
have you ever had like an insanely
wealthy person go I won't need me buy
perf like my personal analyst I did have
one guy who is extremely wealthy but he
wants I can't really discuss the venture
that he wants to do we haven't actually
executed it and we may not but he's got
an idea that that would really change a
lot of things around the league if he
was able to do what he wanted to do
that's all I can say but I love that you
have secrets cuz I can't keep secrets so
this is great like I talk too much I
have a problem yeah it's it's it's fun I
mean you get to meet a lot of people I
mean that's what social media it's so
great because people have the
opportunity just to reach out to you and
communicate with you when did you see
your social media go from I'm I feel
like I'm talking into the void
and I have great things to say and no
one's listening - holy [ __ ] Lois Riddick
is saying this is the [ __ ] man like
when did when did you start to see that
change I think the biggest like flip
came when the Patriots beat the
Jacksonville Jaguars in the AFC
Championship game in 2017 season by
coming from behind by 10 points
Jacksonville was up by 10 in the fourth
quarter with the ball up in New England
and I just ripped the predictable play
calling that Jacksonville had and I had
written about it in my book the prior
year that I was worried about Nathaniel
Hackett because of the way
he calls plays with the lead is gonna
cause this team to lose games and might
even miss the Super Bowl because this
team has some overall count like run run
pass like some sort of money time he was
very predictable at all this every time
yeah it was it was a sequence he had
three possessions in the fourth quarter
he did the same exact play calls on each
of the three possessions and of course
New England snuff them out got the ball
back ended up winning the game and and
that was like Colin coward started
retweeting it saying by this but guys
I'm gonna buy this guy's book next year
and like a lot of people started you
know following me at that point and that
really kind of led the snowball going
down the hill and then this season what
was this season like for you what did it
feel like more pressure because you knew
you had more people watching yeah well
it was that plus it was the fact that
you know working for a team now you want
to try to help them win and so when that
when you're given to a team advise on
suggestions of what to do and they're
not having success like if they lose a
game it was so different compared to
just you know watching the games myself
and not having like you're like okay
what could I have done differently like
you're almost like you're part of a team
even though you're just so what could I
have done differently what other things
could I've analyzed were they using the
stuff that I was recommending enough and
and so there was like a feeling out
process on with that and they started
using the stuff a little bit more but it
was I mean it was it was exciting the
whole season was just exciting because
of the opportunities if you were to self
scout yourself what's something that
maybe you thought was going to go one
way and it didn't or or the analytics
that maybe they lied to you in a way and
I don't know I would have to say one of
the things that I thought that I would
be doing now I'm it was possibly working
full-time for team and actually I was
presented a couple of those
opportunities but I think the consulting
gig is the right fit for me right now
and so that's that's where I'm at and to
come on shows like I get to do shows
with you yeah I get to do more media I
get to have a Twitter account because if
I was working just for one team I'd be
vachs
I'd be like off the radar Cuddy gonna
know where you are who you are yeah and
we've got like now sports betting is
legalized there's so much fun stuff that
we're gonna be able to talk about this
football season and if I was working for
our team I would just be like you said
in a box somewhere and off to the side
no
he would even know what I had to say
about anything to help them process the
game in a little different manner maybe
try to win some money you bet the games
too right well I had in the past but
when I started working for this team
I had to officially agree not to bet the
games that season and that's
understandable so I'd obviously like the
first week second week and then
afterwards it was okay um you know I
found in this business and you tell me
if I'm right that when you make a lot of
your predictions public or you kind of
put your information out there sometimes
that's enough juice to kind of feel it I
know like the money it's it's one way of
doing it but when I have to make my
picks and I know that everybody knows my
pick for that Steelers Patriots game
there's the rush there too I'm on my
seat just like I had a few hundred
dollars or a few dimes on it as well
yeah I'm the problem with me probably
you too like we're just very competitive
that's why we love sports we're just
really competitive people to our core so
it doesn't really matter I could be
betting with you whether like we roll
that football where it's gonna fall off
the table but when we get to generate
I'll do so so we do stuff like that you
know I want to win and so it was the
same way whether or not like I actually
had my cash on that game I know there's
a lot of people are listening to what
I'm saying and putting their cash on it
so I'm just as like upset if it doesn't
go our way and I'm just as ecstatic if
it does do you get a lot of like Twitter
trolls too when you misses something
fortunately not too many and I'm not
sure why that is but I think I think
possibly the reason is they understand
the process like how much work I'm
putting into it and the fact that I will
go out there and the final little bit is
this is what I think is gonna happen but
the prequel to that is all the reasons
why and what ends up happening for a lot
of games is that let's say there's five
reasons why I think a games gonna go my
way or go a certain way I might hit for
the five and everybody can see oh he's
right here he's right here he's right
here yeah
but then he was wrong on this one and
then there was an interception or there
was like a horrible call that went wrong
and then it barely loses like it was
winning at halftime but then it barely
loses okay this is terrible like we hate
the fact that this lost but at least we
understand the process and it was
actually slated to win but some fluke
stuff
happened and so that's the way your
biggest win of all time hmm
that's tough that's a tough one because
I can tell me there was an NDA
I don't know there was no idea I'm gonna
celebrate with you right now
it had to have been the Super Bowl this
this was a lucky one
I was a lucky one but see on the Super
Bowl you can get down a lot more money
than you can on the regular team so when
the Patriots played the Falcons
I took the over in that game nice and
the game was obviously what twenty one
two three at halftime I look like it had
no chance of going over and a lot of the
sharp guys had bet the under there but
we went against them I I don't care what
the public does where the sharp guys do
I know that there's a probably more
value on the sharp side so that's where
I end up more often than not but that's
just because my models will agree with
that but in this case I was riding with
the public and it didn't look like it I
had a chance at halftime so but we had a
fair amount of coin on that game and
luckily it was able to win late go went
to overtime and and we won and that was
a big payday but also it gets
competitive with the sharp groups I
can't I can't get into that but with the
sharp groups I mean the interesting
thing about like advanced level sports
betting is that it you think that we're
competing against the sports books we're
really competing against the other
professional groups really try to get
down on the games at the right time and
at the right number before the other
groups who want to get down the sack
that impact the number so you're always
like I'm I'm not racing or caring what
the public does I look at what the line
is set and then I start saying which of
the games do we want to attack and when
are we going to attack them right
because we need to beat this other group
that has been betting the same game or
were the last three times or we're gonna
lose that number and that's the thing
that like the guys that I work very
closely with in Vegas we talked five six
seven times a day wow they do this for a
living you know we're constantly during
the season talking back and forth that
is the most important thing to them the
line movement if the game loses they're
they're mad but if they got a bad number
then they're even get there and they're
going to be working more mad
or if they if we missed a number you
know we missed the number so we have to
take a worse number and then it loses
all man it's this sounds like the best
fantasy league of all time this founds
this sounds like the underground and I
felt like how many teams would you say
there are like I've note oh of like pro
sports betting groups yeah you know
there's probably 10 to 15 that impact
the market some are big like there's
obviously a couple of really big big
ones super whales
well they're like a llama rate of a few
different guys and they there's so
technical in nature how they get down at
at all different sports books at the
exact same time and the lines will move
tremendous amounts because they're
betting you know there's limits
everywhere and especially early in the
week the limits are even smaller but
when you're forcing action at all these
different books betting at the same time
at all you can you can move the line
tremendously and so there is definitely
one massive group that influences the
market and bets on the games early and
moves the number so there are team that
they're a group that you're always their
names yeah yeah can you say them well
the one group that I'm talking about is
the poker group they call them the poker
group really and like how does a team
get built like it's not like pick up at
the Y like how do you know I mean fine
people you get you get a network of
people a couple sharp guys they want to
raise a bunch of money they have the
they team up together and there's been a
couple groups that have been built
within the last like three to five years
of very and how do you know if somebody
should be on your team like how do you
like if you see someone they're like I
got a lot of money and I'm a shot like
how can you prove that how do you know
that they have the goods you the main
thing if somebody comes to you and if
they've got money then and they want to
help
I will bet the games for you or those
types of things then then you know like
they they're gonna be the ones getting
down there's like 15 other Warren sharps
out there that all these other teams
have many of them there are other people
like me I don't know that they they have
the algorithmic side of it like I do but
they definitely have the algorithm side
of it like I do and they're so there are
different people on different teams very
similar to what I do
and are there algorithms around the
numbers or is it around actual football
likes the
like statistics and charting all that
stuff some of it is play-by-play you
know it depends what different people
you put into their models I mean the
more sophisticated ones will incorporate
play-by-play data for sure Wow have you
ever like has ever been like you're
walking down the streets like Benny and
the Jets or whatever you're like you see
another group and like they're going to
a window and your guys are going to a
window no see fortunately I'm back here
so I don't worry about it I'm gonna go
so it's one of the good things about
being away from Las Vegas is that I can
focus on my work am I in my bunker just
churning away on my algorithms and
watching film and not get caught up at
all and not get caught up in any of the
so that I'm sure there's some times
though where you guys are getting ready
to put in on a number and all of a
sudden the number changes in 20 of times
freaking poker group oh yeah
trust me more often than not it happened
so many times and the other thing that
we can't understand that very that's
infuriating is like when when a team
like a lines being bet up like let's say
a great example last year the Saints
played the Cowboys and the total is
getting been up because it looks like a
the Saints are a high-powered team the
Cowboys like Thursday night game
Thursday night game it ended 10 to 30 13
to 10 Dallas one in a big underdog plus
seven or something but I had that one
that line was getting to total all the
sudden got hammered to the under early
or like why won't these guys just wait
let the public bet this higher and then
get the under at a better number but a
lot of these guys are so based on their
computer model that as soon as it hits a
certain point they'll take it whether or
not the number that they're betting like
under 48 has value versus 47 and a half
or not if it gets to 48 we're betting it
or if it gets to 50 we're betting it
even though like if they would live
waited till I got the 51 that's a much
more valuable number to bet the under at
but they're just so you know it does get
better that's where I'm so funny because
I'll be like the value between a 48 and
a 51 is like epic right I'm sitting
there going if if I would have bet the
under 51 I would have bet it at 48 like
that that's why I'm just a public Joe I
feel it in my bones
well sometimes sometimes the number
matters I mean it's rare that like you
would if if my model for instance for
instance said the number should be
51 and a half right I'm not gonna bet
the under if the under is sitting at 52
there's just not enough value there but
if so that's where like if the number
was 53 then I'm betting it if the number
is 52 then I'm not and you might say
well the number is 51
I'd like the under just because I like
the under it really two teams you could
set the total whatever as long as it's
not 37 I'm betting the over because I
just think you know I or I'm betting the
under because I just think this lines
too high right so yeah its value is very
big you look at the NFL now through a
prism and and you have all your graphs
and your charts and and Ike it's very
easy to see visually again I would
implore you to go to sharp football
analysis calm just play around like mess
around with the different sliders and
check out different things and if you
have a favorite team kind of check out
your own team see what they're
successful let's see what they're not
successful it's it's a fun way to look
at football who do you think in the NFL
is it is it the Patriots and everybody
else in terms of analytics just yeah in
terms of looking at the game course or
the way that you do and at the way maybe
it should be going I think there's a few
other teams I mean like the Eagles and
some things Howie Roseman is doing with
the front office there I know that
interacting comp picks your thing on
complex lately I think is called a lot
of attention just the availability of
getting picks by not spending a lot in
free agency letting certain guys walk
making trades and getting picks and that
doesn't mess up your models and then
also signing guys that were released
during free agency and the last three
years since how we got back you've shown
they're right up there with the Patriots
they're getting more value than the
Patriots thus far through this offseason
yeah through this offseason they have
and one of the things I mean like the
Eagles how we didn't have control when
Chip Kelly was there so once he got
control back from chip they did they
were more active in free agency which
means they didn't have as many complex
but Howie even yesterday at some of the
owners meetings was talking about the
value of complex and how they're playing
that game to try to get those picks so
it is there there's analytics at so many
different levels it's at the front
office it's in free agency its its with
trades it's at the team level its with
roster building it's with game
management its with fourth quarter
timeout decisions it's with
play calls sure it's like so many
different levels of it and there are
definitely teams besides the Patriots
that are getting much better at rolling
it all up and incorporating it I worry
that the teams the very low end of the
spectrum you know teams like the Arizona
Cardinals and teams that are bad like
they're more invested in like their new
coaches or the coaches on the hot seat
those guys aren't going to be like all
the sun wanting to jump into analytics
so they're not gonna have the edges that
the really good coaches who have got
long track records might be like we know
how hard it is to win we want every
frickin edge possible to win some of
these games and so those guys are going
to invest more in analytics and that's
why I view this as like more its
potential to become more of like the
haves and have-nots where the teams that
are using the analytics more and diving
more into it are the better teams to
begin with and so they're gonna continue
that dominance whereas the teams that
are bad where coaches are fighting and
you know there's a lot of turnover there
those teams might be like you know they
aren't going to incorporate analytics is
how many halves do you think we have
right now I'd say probably around seven
eight can you like who would they be so
Eagles Patriots egos Patriots I think
the Colts
I think the Chiefs are pretty good from
that perspective they pass a lot on
first down let's see over an NFC I would
have to say I think that the Saints are
a little bit you know the Saints are a
little bit there although they're not
playing the comp pick game they don't
overcome they haven't had a complex at
all but they're doing a lot with some of
the ways that they utilize their players
let's see it's it's a tough question to
name them all but those are like five I
think we listed right there easier to
have nots than the haves yeah I mean
they have nots like even a team like the
Baltimore Ravens right they're a very
good team but they in the Seattle
Seahawks okay it is possible to be a
good team and to be focused on some of
the things that aren't that successful
but you have a pretty good roster and
you've got a good schedule and injury
Luck's going your way so you're able to
win games I mean the the the way that
the Ravens are building themselves with
Lamar Jackson a lot of the ground game
obviously we know rushing is not as
efficient as passing but when you create
like such mismatches because no other
team plays like that and the defense has
to adjust for one week
to figure out how to stop you but the
problem is their ceiling is very limited
because they're not going to get at
least last year especially they're not
to get 14 point leads on teams you know
the games are going to be tighter and so
one fumble can turn everything we saw
against the Chargers and relay offs a
team like the Seattle Seahawks you know
they want a lot of games last year but
well then when they go to the playoffs
and they're playing another good offense
and they're trying to stick with their
we want to run the football and they're
playing a good run defense and then they
keep running and even though the runs
not working like you've got to adapt but
what about the Patriots because I
thought this was the year of the
Patriots where they kind of moved to a
power running scheme well what the
Patriots did is they use a lot of 21
personnel with the running back out
there on the field James Devlin and most
teams don't play 21 personnel and so it
catches the defense off guard with hey
this fullbacks in here and they're gonna
run power offense at us and so you're
able to do a lot of different things out
of that like they still pass the ball a
lot out of that but the way the Patriots
work if it's in their best interest to
run the ball they're gonna run the ball
and if it's in their best interest to
pass the ball they're gonna pass it if
they play a top 5 run defense they're
gonna come out the first series and try
to run the ball a little bit if it
doesn't work Tom Brady's thrown 50
passes in that game the rest how many
other teams are able to adjust like
they'll know one that's the one clear
thing that the Patriots have such a
dominance is the confidence in the
coaches and the what they've taught the
players that they can adapt a game plan
and modify it on the spot drop a brand
new type of play and have perfect
confidence that it's gonna get executed
and carried out the rest of the way it's
like every four other teams watch it's
it's incredible yeah is that just like
because we've talked so many times about
Belichick in his head this encyclopedia
all the plays that I've ever been called
and knows exactly what to do and he's
just sitting there with his card and his
pencil he's like we're gonna change this
and we're gonna change that can it
really all just be that one man I think
he's got a very good staff behind him
you know like that are behind the scenes
I mean josh mcdaniels is very smart
Hoffman's coordinator of course they
cycle a lot of defense coordinators
through there you know and some of them
don't have quite as much success when
they leave that leave the patriot system
but it's a lot easier to look better
when you got Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick softens on the other side of
you
but bill bill bill belichick probably
the best coach in NFL history you know
Walsh was amazing too I mean there's a
few that are up there like at the
pinnacle but Bill Belichick is
incredible especially in this day and
age of like free agency you know you
know it's in the salary cap you know the
things that they've been doing part of
it is you know they've been able to work
great deal for Tom Brady he doesn't hit
the cap for you know even a top 10
quarterback and Gronk wasn't even its
cap for more like a top-five tight end
even though they're both clearly the
best at their positions in the NFL
that's what's wild is from a cat
building team perspective to get what
they've gotten out of Brady and Gronk I
don't know if we'll ever see again and
and I typically will always stand for
the players I call this the players
podcast because I want these guys to get
paid I see the human element you know I
look at Le'Veon Bell go no he needs
guaranteed money because of the position
and the injuries and all that stuff and
I look at Gronk and I'm sitting there on
set and I'm with Tony Delk and I'm with
Andy cats and all these and and Gronk
retires and I go guys he played nine
years how much money do you think Gronk
made over nine years someone's had a
hundred ninety I got him at 85 fifty
nine million dollars over nine years
that's nothing that's it's it's like six
and a half million dollars a year so
they're the best tight end of all time
are the Patriots who were great at the
foresight where the he only played two
years and he had two years left on his
deal after the first two years they
signed him to a six-year extension but
the fact that Gronk like so many players
around league did not beg or hold out
for a new contract he was under contract
on that second deal for eight years
because it added six to the two before
so we had an eight year deal that went
through 2019 and he did not hold out
once he did not say these underpaid
wants the last two years 2017 2018 they
added some incentives to his deal but
that's it he kept the same cap head he
kept the same base salary and and that
just doesn't happen I mean you see
Le'Veon you see Antonio that's just had
one team you know complaining and
they're like greats amongst their
position but definitely not the
clear-cut best like rohnke it makes me
my conspiracy theory is
well craft is hooking them up outside
the game then the other part of me is
sometimes I get a little upset at Grunk
I go of anybody that was supposed to up
the tight-end market it was supposed to
be him because I'm looking at the salary
cap going up every year and I know what
I'm saying is awful strategy for a team
awful but I think about all I think
about Kelsey I think about all these
other tight ends that I want to cash in
but all those teams can go well Gronk
only made fifty nine right it's the
ultimate leverage point now for every
team because he's freaking drunk it's
crazy to me but that's the Patriots and
I think when you buy into a system at
Trent Brown we had him on and his
episode came out on Tuesday and he said
when I went to the Patriots I fell in
love with the game again and that's the
other thing that these other teams can't
give them they walk into the locker room
there's no [ __ ] it's it's like radio
love em
where they don't have any corporate
politics because everybody just speaks
their mind all the time you go to New
England Tom Brady is right there in the
meeting sitting in the front row there's
no nonsense and that's part of the value
and you know you have a chance to win a
championship every year so as a player
you want to be a part of that but crazy
so Patriots are up there Eagles are up
there you want to do some news with me
really quick what did you think of Gronk
retiring and like analytics perspective
how great of a tight end was he I mean
he's clear-cut the best I mean he's
better than most wide receivers like in
terms of his yards per attempt and his
success rate so I mean he's he's just
ridiculous in the fact that he did it
with such longevity year after year
after year the problem is his body kind
of gave out on everybody was going he
was less productive in 2018 obviously
and that's probably one of the reasons
why he wanted to walk away when he still
had a little bit more the health plus
he's gonna have I already didn't even
spend a dollar of that fifty nine
million and he's been living off
endorsements now he's gonna have a lot
more opportunity to make more money on
endorsements oh yeah they're still
upside and he always has a chance to
come back look his salaries have about
his cap hit for the Patriots this year I
think was going to be 11 or 12 million
dollars and it was the number one
highest cap hit of any tight end so now
what the Patriots get to do is they get
to take that 12 million yep
stick it back and
sitting other players obviously they may
have to draft it I tend to reverse them
right but now if Gronk comes back later
in the season they don't have to give
him a cap hit of that much money so they
could still have him for the playoffs
save all that cap hit I mean it could
end up working in the Patriots favor
long-term I think it will be I when
Rosenhaus came out the next day and said
hey Tom he calls him up middle of the
season I could see him making a comeback
I went that's happening why would you
float that out like in what interest as
Rosenhaus have going it's not like he
said Gronk can sign with another team he
just said that team I think it's a
hundred percent happening warrant do you
feel with me there I feel like I I don't
know the hunger but I think it's above
50 I think see I just throw out numbers
alright so I have to do a little bit of
whoa big offseason these are stories
that get a lot of attention and they're
not really stories and I can't believe
we're talking about him we are in the
midst of the greatest whoa big off
season season I've ever seen offseason
two weeks ago Cam Newton came out and
said he's going vegan and we have had a
long history on this program warren of
guys going vegan and I think it's
actually shown that it's it's not worked
in the NFL it's been negative for
Demaryius Thomas Adrian Peterson I think
it was a joke Theo Riddick but like all
these stories and every single one of
them have had issues as their careers
gone on but then he's on the James
Corden show and he says he's not
climaxing for the entire month of April
not taking care of himself not having
sex anything and it's all to test his
mental strength Cam Newton already is
gonna go into the whoa big offseason
Hall of Fame the strategy is interesting
I guess the question I ask myself is
could I have that mental fortitude I
just met you I don't think I can do it I
think that if cam is able to do this I
worry about the first guy that's gonna
try and tackle him this season because
the amount of strength and I don't know
if you can chart this that he's gonna
take out on a line back
is gonna be immense but I'm also worried
is cam having a mental breakdown is this
like a midlife crisis right now is it
because he's seeing Norv Turner and he's
like I have to play with this guy like
what like what's going on right now in
Cam's head that he's changing everything
I don't have the answer I'm just amazed
by what cams to it Warren I really am
I agree I don't know that there's any
realistic reason for this except just
like a ridiculous challenge for himself
you know like you said to see what he's
going to do but I it's it's real-life
Seinfeld to be honest with you ya know
the bet with George and Elaine yeah you
know there's a few different episodes of
Seinfeld that touch on him out touch on
various different things but remember
when George our guests abstained and
became Intel extremely intelligent and
Layne did this no way it came really
stupid and and that was just a hilarious
episode and and then and then George
finally you speaking my language was
Seinfeld George finally got lucky and
then and then became just the idiot I
believe yes so of course I mean it's
gonna be interesting to see what cams
mental acuity is after this and then
then measure it you know to what happens
they should do he should take wonder
licks and a bunch of other like mental
tests wonder let everybody do amble
right in right after April yeah yeah
give him like give him like a week of
being back to normal
hello and then and then test him again I
just yeah all of a sudden he's just like
taking pictures inside the library and
he has an engineering degree all of a
sudden he's doing online courses at
Phoenix I am so curious and then I'm all
these stories I want to break it down to
the like the Panthers what did you think
of how they approached the season last
year ton of Christian McCaffrey catching
the ball did you like what they did they
started off so strong it imploded in
Pittsburgh and then it was an epic
collapse the rest of the way how did you
see their season going before the injury
I guess yeah I changed everything it did
change at the very end um I think
overall it was about what we expected
you know I I thought that norm did
better than some people anticipated
myself included yeah yeah it was very
questioning of that and and I think they
did a great job with incorporating cam
into that style and getting him to do
stuff that he wasn't doing in the past
under his prior coordinators the you
kristan McCaffrey and using him a lot of
a backfield as a pass catcher was
obviously great I mean they didn't have
the best weapons at wide receiver either
so they may do with a lot of things in a
very difficult division I think they had
overall like a fairly successful season
and I think that's why you know all the
coaching staff except the defense corner
is back for this upcoming season so I
think they need to build on that my
concern is Kristian McCaffrey's usage
you know that they're going to scale
that and ratchet that down
they said we think he can run between
the tackles and a lot of people said oh
you're crazy you can't do that in the
NFL but then he was having success but
the problem was they get you used him so
much in the run game plus the pass game
that over you know if you want this guy
to be your running back through this
contract and into the next one
you need to like massage him a little
bit more and give some rest to him a
little bit this is like the Evan Silva
section of the pod where we talk about
running backs and say qalam barkley and
taking them number two overall but also
like with Christian McCaffrey Alvin
Kamara these guys are so phenomenal and
I think that they can be more dangerous
than an X receiver or a Z receiver how
are they supposed to use them how do you
not give that guy the ball every time
how'd what do you think how do you
stretch that out but also maximize the
potential yeah you call run plays when
it's an optimal situation to run the
football so you don't waste run plays
which are going to give anytime you're
running you're running back up the
middle sorry my nose is running I was
outside with Josh in 30-degree weather
and I weather and I may be sick so if I
keep touching my nose I apologize all
right I'll just I would just say over
there okay so I'll keep my distance but
what I think that they should be doing
is run the ball when it's optimal don't
run it when it's not and when you're
running the football so there's
different times to be like not on second
and ten not on second and ten gosh don't
run the ball as much when you're backed
up inside your own 20 like those are
actually plus V's situations to pass the
football coaches get conservative oh we
need to run the ball but if you want to
get in a first down and not have to punt
the ball back and give your opponent
good field position you're gonna want to
pass the ball because those are
situations where the defense tends to
play run so you want to run when the
defense is playing pass and you want to
pass when the defense is possibly
playing run right and you want to be
using your running back intelligently as
a receiver out of the backfield and
running in these optimal situations
which includes short yardage red zone
not as much first in ten
like you just there's ways that you can
optimize increased yeah you need to
increase your running backs longevity in
his career but not anytime you're
running through your own offensive line
and then the defensive line and then
linebackers it's a lot of people fall on
it you're running back trying to hit him
you throw the ball to this guy out on
the perimeter he sees heads up to the
guy who's trying to tackle them can make
a move one man escape escape run out of
bounds there's a lot of ways that you
can decrease the amount of hits that he
takes if you use him more in the past
I'm really concerned about sake one like
his legs are right behind you right now
if you go all the way and they're a
marvel of human existence those are
those are impressive yeah so I'm at
Sloan he was least but with Odell gone
like I'm really concerned about Seiko on
this season like very concerned because
if they're gonna act this I don't say
Neanderthal --is-- but behind in the
times I think they're just gonna pound
the rock like 400 times within next
season the problem is is to lose lose
because you've got Eli Manning a
quarterback so if you draft a
quarterback and you got a young guy out
there who ends up starting at some point
during the year you're gonna want to
earn the ball because it's not
experienced but you got Eli who doesn't
have Odell and doesn't have a strong arm
right you're going to need to run the
ball to keep him protected so it's a
lose-lose situation it's a lot of say
Kwan carries all right another whoa big
offseason the opposite of Cam Newton
going vegan is Jameis Winston wanting to
bulk up to 250 to handle the hits
I remember when Jameis first came out
there was that one picture of fat Jameis
where he was dropping back and it looked
like he had a gut I'm all-in on fat
Jameis not saying that I think he's
gonna have a great season but there's
obviously an insert crabs crab legs joke
here but I'm just imagining Jameis
constantly eating in practice and
constantly eating in the meeting room
and just going around and like launching
his own line of ribs I don't know why I
find Jameis when he's not doing all the
field things that really scared
me and I find grotesque to be somewhat
funny and I think him ballooning up to
250 it sounds like the worst idea I've
ever heard but I still want to see it
not my team yeah I don't know what how
what is he at now I mean like right bet
that he's played probably close to 250
before right I don't know exactly what
we're talking about Laurence assumed
he's in like the to 35 to 40 he's I
think in a certain age right it's never
a good idea to put on weight like just
to put on weight like if we says you
know we know that that's not great I
know that Bruce Arians with Ben
Roethlisberger when they were together
now Bruce is down in Tampa worse like
Ben was getting hit a lot so you know
they may be he's like doing that to try
to prepare himself to play quarterback
and Bruce Arians offense we're hanging
of the pocket and take more hits but
does does adding like five pounds of fat
to your gut is that gonna save you from
getting somebody driving at your knees i
mean i don't know so i look at Jameis
and I mean where is he in terms of like
looking at quarterbacks analytically his
decision-making sometimes is the worst
thing I've ever seen yeah if you could
process decision-making I can create a
variable for that right he would be near
the bottom but his in terms of his
passing and some of the success that
he's had in Tampa over the last few
years he's actually not been bad not
been bad better than what most people
would anticipate from him in terms of
some of his actually in his passing
numbers yards per attempt but it starts
rolling around yeah he does so many
stupid things but he also has a plethora
of talent there you know they have to
show they had Chris God when they have
great tight ends like Mike Evans so I
mean they're like so you know your
quarterback is a product of your
coordinator the play calls and the
talent surrounding you and he had a ton
of great receivers surrounding him
unbelievable and then the this is the
most interesting whoa big offseason Jay
Groot were staying with food again Jay
Gruden on Colt McCoy he drinks of gallon
of milk every day and I think it's the
milk that's not pasteurized either quote
I think it's right out the teat this guy
is a nut job Colt McCoy could be the
starting quarterback of Washington next
season apparently he drinks a gallon
of milk everyday we've seen this with
like Jim Harbaugh before people that are
obsessed with the milk in this era where
people don't even drink cow's milk I
don't know how that came up Warren and I
don't know why it came up and I don't
know if it makes me more or less
confident in Colt McCoy as a quarterback
well I think he's doing it because of
the injury to his leg you know and and
and trying to get the extra calcium but
there's a thing right now called like
supplements and you could take pills
that are just here calcium I don't
understand animal milk like is is I
don't know some people don't react very
well to it like it's a foreign here's me
apart and so it causes some problems
lactose etc so I don't really know if
it's the smartest idea to take on
another like seemingly unnecessary
challenge if you want to increase the
calcium take a supplement this is I've
never seen a coach more dead man walking
than Jay Gruden and it's been a very
interesting week he had he looked dead
in the picture of the coach's photo
literally and then now he's got this
quote about milk and this entire season
with Alex Smith maybe never gonna play
football again maybe trading up for a
quarterback it just feels like it's like
the Dwyane Wade farewell tour for Jay
Gruden like it's it seems like it's a
foregone conclusion he's done and we
just get to watch him suffer all year
long well you know they said that he was
hearing about the free agent moves
through social media the they weren't
even consulting him on any of that yeah
which is totally bizarre I mean George
Allen the the the I guess he's like the
VP but he's calling the shots there so
Bruce Allen I'm sorry that's his dad
George Bruce Allen not very smart and
savvy when it comes out at all making
moves and the team is like got the third
worst record in the NFL since he took
over and and then to suggest that like
we want him to buy all the ingredients
for the coach just makes absolutely no
sense and then Jay you're right I mean
it's like a sad situation and I think it
was just personified in that team photo
all right so my last thing is you're
very good at predictive data the guy the
announcer that's been all about
predicting is Tony Romo and Tony Romo is
about to navigate an amazing negotiation
come out and their stories right now
that he's looking for a contract worth
10 million dollars per year which would
make him the highest-paid sports analyst
of all time he's going into his third
season so his contracts coming up soon
talk about hitting the market at the
right time and then when I read the
story that he it's not about going to
another network
he might just want to stop there's part
of me that once Tony Romo to do three
years and then be done and be and he'll
go down is one of the greatest
announcers has ever been there because
it's been so impactful through those
three years being an announcer is not as
glamorous as it may seem it's a lot of
traveling you're not home at all he's
got a lot of young kids really he's the
first announcer I've ever seen that's
celebrated usually you're picked apart
all your mistakes but I think he's worth
ten million dollars per year I really do
like I can't imagine how much Jim Nantz
is getting paid but if if Gruden was
getting in the sixes and sevens and Tony
Romo has now worked himself into where
when he says something we all believe it
and we kind of go well who would you
want on the cult I'd like Tony Romo on
the call
I also curious what you think of his
predicting of plays throughout his
career thus far I might be a little bit
different than the typical sports fan
yeah but I want to be taught I want
somebody who's gonna give me information
with them listening to your show I'm
listening to football on Sunday on radio
I want somebody who's going to educate
me a little bit so that I can leave that
having enjoyed it like I wanted to
experience I also want to walk away with
like this sense that like I didn't waste
my time like I actually maybe learn
something that I'll be able to use in
the future Tony Romo does that he
provides that education to the common
fan I love it
the fact that he's pressing and is able
to predict a lot of the playoffs I think
is fun it's fun it's like a roll of dice
is Tony gonna be right oh my god he's
right again so that's like an other Le
right ho-ho identify formations he'll
identify emotional say you got to look
here and if that sound up and good he's
so good at breaking down plays
afterwards I thought that was what
Gruden did really well but then Gruden
kind of became a caricature of himself
later on
like smoothies and hotdogs and all that
stuff but in the beginning he was
showing us things we hadn't seen before
Colin Cris Collinsworth I feel like kind
of goes through and don't you love this
he's like an appreciation of the game
but he's very good I think an
identifying like in the trenches showing
the blockers and missing all that stuff
and then whom I'm akin and Buck is a
talk show like that has to be your least
favorite one of the four but you know
what the same thing I can speak because
I don't really care but I think Tony
Romo has put himself into a position
where two years ago I doubted him I
didn't know if he was gonna be good at
this and now I don't think it's crazy
that he's looking for 10 million dollars
a year the way I always feel about money
is that you need to obviously he needs
to go after what he thinks he's worth of
course but if there's no cap there's no
cap on announcers then pay what you need
yes get him on board right because the
people care about it and want to hear
about it that's why when you when you're
coaching a team and or you're the owner
of a team why wouldn't you want to pay a
bunch of coaches and bringing a lot of
talented coaches it doesn't hurt the
salary capital so that you you have to
work within the parameters of the salary
cap but apart from that pay your people
so pay Tony Romo whatever you think he's
worth to get him in there because he's
gonna keep eyeballs on you're you're
talking to the guy that last year
thought the Giants should have paid 20
million dollars a year to get Belichick
and if he wanted 30 I to give them 30
what's it to the merits really who cares
I mean it and what it's gonna do to your
franchise the eyeballs and then also the
longevity of success afterwards
absolutely Warren this was an absolute
pleasure I really appreciate you again
follow him on social media at sharp
football check out his website sharp
football analysis dot-com I hope this is
not the last time I talk to you I'd like
to pick your brain even more but thank
you for making me a better better and
I'm gonna sound smarter when I talk to
people later today so I appreciate it
pal
let's do it again I would fist bump you
but you've witnessed me today and it's
disgusting Warren you're the man to the
homies I am the lef koe man I will see
you guys on Tuesday
keep kicking ass keep being great people
holler at you soon
[Music]